[Music]
[Applause]
tonight you got the Cowboys and the
Giants we bring in Ross Tucker our good
buddy from leswood one he's joining us
on behalf of DraftKings he's the host of
even money betting podcast and a game
analyst for CBS Westwood one and the
Philadelphia Eagles let me start with
the Eagles uh any negatives there after
three weeks
not really Dan I mean they've got a
couple penalties that they can clean up
but they have a really really good team
I think it probably started with their
decision on the preseason game analyst I
think that's when things started to
really take off for this franchise no
Dan you know here's what I've been
saying to people because I do a lot of
stuff in Philly
it's the best corners they've had in a
long time best linebackers they've had
in a long time it's the best offensive
line in the NFL it's easily the best
receiving core they've had in a long
time maybe ever I mean Devante Smith was
unbelievable yesterday AJ Brown's a stud
Dallas got her to top five receiver
Jalen hurts has improved way more than
even I thought he would they just have a
really good team now look the playoffs
are a long way away A lot can happen
between now and then but they have a
loaded roster that so far this year is
playing very well it seems like they're
the most balanced team in the NFC and I
always look at offensive lines and
defensive lines how good are you they
got depth at the offense or defensive
line positions and if you throw in some
weapons there I mean it really comes
down to if they're going to be great
it'll be because of Jalen hurts and if
they're not then they might be good is
that going to be good enough because I
look at Green Bay and I feel like this
is who Green Bay is they don't have
anybody they're waiting for whereas the
Buccaneers are getting some people back
seems like we forgot about the Rams
after the loss to Buffalo uh so if
you're looking at handicapping the NFC
or the Eagles the best team in the NFC
well what the way you just described it
Dan I agree 100 with what you said about
the other teams and certainly what you
said about the Eagles I think that they
objectively have the best roster in the
NFC and they're up there in terms of
best rosters in the NFL so far they've
stayed very healthy they've only lost
Derek Barnett but they had the best
o-line their d-line had nine sacks
yesterday now a lot of that was Carson
wentz's refusal to get rid of the ball
or throw the ball away but still nine
sacks is nine sacks there's no one that
has a better roster than them the
question will be
how good is their record in terms of
home to an advantage or you know what
seed they are and then when they get to
the playoffs how well does Jalen hurts
play versus Aaron Rodgers in a playoff
game versus Tom Brady in a playoff game
because remember it was just this past
January Dan that he was clearly
outplayed by Tom Brady it wasn't even
close now he's improved a lot and the
roster has improved tremendously around
him and it feels like the Bucks and
Packers and even the Rams have all kind
of taken a step back and come back to
the pack a little bit
the Dolphins
yeah if you're going to script it uh
don't think you could have scripted any
better than what we've seen so far it
was a great month they made a they may
be the team of the month but how do you
look at this bigger picture with the
dolphins are they going to be right
there with the Buffalo Bills by the end
of the year yeah I think though I think
they will be I think they'll be in the
mix and here's why when you get a new
coach and I can speak to this and I
think this relates a little bit also Dan
to what's going on with Doug Peterson in
Jacksonville who's won back-to-back
games by 24 points when you get a new
head coach and I had a bunch of them you
start to get rolling a little bit early
you you think you're as good as anyone
you think like well now that we got this
coach who knows what he's doing we can
beat anybody so the vibe right now in
Jacksonville and in Miami is amazing and
to gut through the last couple wins the
way they did the comeback in Baltimore
holding on against I think the bills had
the ball for like 90 some plays the
Dolphins had it for 39 I mean any
statistical measure the Dolphins should
not have won that game but they found a
way credit to their defense because I
thought their offensive score a lot more
points the bills were missing six
defensive starters six so I thought it'd
be a way higher scoring game and the
Dolphins might win like 34-31 it wasn't
it was the Dolphins defense getting
after Josh Allen making him fumble
Oddball was great Melvin Ingram was
great and they're really building
something down there with Mike McDaniel
what did you see on the two a tongue of
iloa hit and then when he got up uh on
his uh on his two feet
yeah I talked about this already Dan as
well on the Ross Tucker podcast this
morning it's a bad look for the NFL and
you know how I know that
because yesterday I got at least three
text messages from people that never
text me about football
my mom's texted me why is Tua back in
the game even like our friends that live
across the street they're like they
never text me about football I thought
the NFL had a concussion protocol why is
Tua back in
and I I don't have a great answer for
them Dan I know they're saying that it
was a back injury
look I'm on The Dan Patrick Show there's
millions of people whatever listening or
watching I'm not going to sit here and
say people are lying
um I would just say that if I had to bet
on it or if you're asking me Ross what
do you think
I I think it was a head injury I mean
you're talking about a guy I've had a
back surgery I've had back spasms my
whole life I mean I've had head injuries
but they would have to conspire to give
us a different story
well
when they bring them off to the side
if all he talks about is his back and
says no I'm fine my head was fine it's
my back it's my back
at that point you know my understanding
is if the if they clear them on the
concussion protocol then they clear them
it really comes down to they believed
that him wobbling was a result of the
back because if they think he's wobbling
because of the head injury he's
automatically out you're automatically
out if they think that that that visible
wobbling is a cognitive thing I just I
mean Dan and I hope everyone's telling
the truth I hope it was his back I hope
it was in his head two things I'll say
about that though number one
his head snapped back and hit the the
back of the turf he grabbed his face
mask like that
then he gets up and like shakes off the
cobwebs then he takes a couple steps and
then starts to get wobbly
I don't know and here's the other thing
they're gonna do an investigation and at
some point They will announce the
results of the investigation you know
who won't hear about those results and
doesn't care my mom or my friends down
the street that's why either way it's a
really bad look for the NFL because
those people saw what they saw and they
don't think it was his back so no matter
what the NFL does to try to make
everybody feel better about it most of
the Casual fans that only watch on
Sunday that's all they just watch the
games on Sunday they've already kind of
made their decision
well you bring up The Telltale sign to
me is head snaps back hits the turf and
then he shakes his head he never grabs
his back
you've had back surgery and I've had
back issues if your back goes out or you
have that you know sharp pain you know
you wince in a different way and then he
starts to stumble a little bit and we've
seen players before when they get up
their Bell is rung and they stumble in
the same manner Heinz Ward once told me
that he got his Bell rung he immediately
grabbed his ankle just to say to the
staff and the Steelers hey I'm not
coming out of this game even though I
got my bell rung and they said no they
had to hide his helmet from him because
they knew that he obviously got his Bell
rung I I hope the Dolphins are being
transparent here but you can't tell me
that his reaction was oh my back when
he's shaking his head grabbing his face
mask and then he stumbles that stumble
is attributed to a concussion
then
I've had a lot of back issues
I've never once grabbed my face mask or
shaken my head when my back hurts that's
just not the reaction that's just not
what you do and I've had a bunch of back
spasms and stuff had a herniated disc
two herniated discs I I never like
wobbled like that I never stumbled so I
don't look they're doing an
investigation I just I guess my question
would be what's the solution then like
let's Advance the story if the player
says it's not his head it's his back
oh I I are you supposed to call him a
liar they supposedly did I mean they
still had to do the independent
neurological exam and he passed it
evidently
I'm watching the video again
that's it
it doesn't make sense and you know what
Dan more important than any and look
it'll be talked about a lot we'll hear
about the investigation
the court of public opinion is what
matters
to the NFL and the court my mom people
down the street how they feel the NFL
handles these issues that's what matters
so maybe they'll absolve the dolphins of
any wrongdoing but then they're going to
have to come up with something else
where if a guy wobbles he's out no
matter what because you can't you just
can't have this you can't have millions
of people watching a guy appear to hit
his head wobble and then go back in the
game it it it does so much damage to how
much we've Advanced that topic we're
talking to Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one
color analyst joining us on behalf of
DraftKings
how are the Raiders how would you feel
if you're Josh McDaniels today
really bad
really bad because not only are they
over three they've lost three close
games and I've always felt like Dan
close games
more than even any other game are really
a reflection of the head coach coaching
the quarterback
and I think on some level Josh McDaniels
was set up to fail in the sense that
remember last year remember how many
close games they won with Rich bisaccia
Rich Visage interim head coach special
teams guy they won close game after
close game to make the playoffs they
almost knocked off the Bengals in the
Wild Card round and now you bring in
McDaniels there's only one 0-3 team in
the NFL and I like Josh I played for
Josh in New England I think he's a
really smart coach but the proof is in
the pudding they've had three
opportunities to win games late they
haven't been able to get it done I blame
Mark Davis I blame the owner who for
whatever reason Dan thought he was too
good for Rich basaccia I'm too good for
this guy or maybe it's because Gruden
had brought Versace in as a special
teams coordinator we had a small sample
size with bisaccia but it was good it
was a good sample size it was the only
sample size there's no negative there's
no bad sample size of a shot you why
they wouldn't continue that why they
wouldn't build on that is beyond me and
I feel like on some level this is
football Karma Mark Davis thought he was
too good for Rich Versace and he's being
shown that that was not the case
the butt pump uh punt or the butt fumble
which one more embarrassing and orlovsky
out of the end zone when he played for
the Lions or Jimmy G last night oh okay
so first of all
um the the butt punt is worse than the
butt fumble you know I mean Sanchez ran
into the back of Brandon Moore whatever
the butt fumble I mean he literally
kicked it into the guy's butt
as for orlowsky we need to clear
something up right now I like Dan
rolowsky I'm friends with him I'm happy
for his success in the media but those
two aren't even close go back and watch
Dan watch the Orlowski okay I mean Jimmy
G was like backing up and his heel or
whatever hit the back of the end line
orlovsky looked like it was recess and
he thought the end line was no man's
land and Jared Allen couldn't touch him
orlowsky's running he ran like eight
yards a yard and a half out of bounds
Orlowski that's I love you Dan not you
Dan Patrick I'm talking to Orlowski Now
by far the worst I've ever seen people
need to stop comparing it Orlowski
thought he was in no man's land it was
like in the no touch Zone and Jimmy G's
got to be grateful that he did step on
the end line because it would have been
a pick six
absolutely he did not look good boy that
game last night I you know I can't wait
till the ratings for last night's game
comes out because that will be proof of
our addiction like that will be proof of
like okay maybe America has a problem
now if if 20 million people watched that
game last night we might need help we
might need to talk to somebody about
this because the Broncos had nine three
an ounce in an NFL football game not at
home nine three an ounce and they won
yeah and they're two and one they feel
like they're all in three
it's one of the worst two and ones you
can have how about the bears being two
in one yeah Justin field I mean I know
that's Paulie's team Justin Fields
couldn't possibly look worse they're two
and one by the way how are you feeling
if you're a Raiders fan and like the
Bears are two and one the Broncos are
two and one and you've got Devonte Adams
and Renfro and Waller and you're Owen
three what a bad bad luck what happens
tonight one way or another they'll be
overreaction the Giants win
that reaction the Cowboys win with
Cooper Rush
oh that's a great Point great Point
um I think the Cowboys probably win a
close game only because I just can't
picture this Giants team being 3-0 if
Giants team gets the three to throw with
another close game day ball will be like
the anti-josh McDaniels they'll be like
the the exact opposite because I've
watched the Giants game saquan but they
don't look that good I mean Daniel Joe
it's not like Daniel Jones even playing
better than he has been they're just
making that one play or two late in the
game to win which is a big part of this
league
always great to talk to you thank you
buddy absolutely thank you Dan that's
Ross Tucker joining us on behalf of
DraftKings also he's the CBS Westwood
one color analyst and host of the Ross
Tucker football podcast
it's not good I know I love his energy